all the attachments of humanity Beijing
nothing
you
sup guys so the plan for today is going
to be doing all that green screen
elements I'll be filming here at the
extra factory space we have the scene
when it gravity reverses and they fly up
onto the other side of the bridge so to
pull it off we're going to build a
spherical panoramic 3d environment with
3d elements we have to get all the
people elements first which will be
filling here on wires to get to take a
look ultimate real that's about it at
the moment that's all I got I feel
really cool I feel like a cool person
that I'm becoming Alex fans um I played
it a little bit so I'm familiar with the
keyboard control I'm doing wire work not
quite sure I'm getting thrown into
something or falling off something it's
fun you know when you play a woman you
don't always get like the hard gritty
stuff so you get to play a guide so yeah
it's not like flailing like as if you
confuse it kind of freaking out and
seeing except to give yourself like some
rotation forward and stuff
yeah perfect surf loading in the air and
this is the wide shot of you following
up to the bridge so if you can do the
more like upside down and flipping you
can get the better it'll be okay it's
just all about as much motion sometimes
you can lose the gun to pretty much
three months that's a lot over that's a
slim over you're like I can't like
explain it I just have to like do it
just do it Sam
Jody like me go ahead yeah something
like it's like trying to like and I
might come in from this side I don't
know maybe yeah you see how that's more
of a sideways rolled and straight over
so I'm Sol view it right I'll just keep
doing it until you're like stop that's
nice that's nice cool double roll be a
little bit faster if possible
that'd be appreciated that's it so last
night when we're working on the costumes
Sam comes up he's like hey kind of need
another gravity gun that like can take a
hit or take a fall I was okay I guess
we'll make a grab you throw together in
like a couple hours the actual one we
have the real one is really really nice
but it's very fragile it's really heavy
in the shots where she's like flying up
and stuff she does have to worry about
dropping this super heavy
crappy guns so there's a dump in there
for nothing yeah there for nothing guys
we'll just replace me with Alex in the
other video alrighty Sam right yeah
cool and cut natural ideally don't flip
over completely right away he's a little
bit slow that said that wasn't bad but
just one right we going to be reaching
and kind of going upside down like you
reached when you view the back okay
three two one drop
now we're gonna now we'll do almost the
full speed ahead
she's like really happy about it and
I'll make sure to turn later not to put
your elbows down so much kind of what be
more in your chest and I'm gonna take
out I'm gonna hold the slack on you so
you you're not going to hit as hard nice
so again lon feel free to take up any
moment Damon feel free to say cut it
here was wrong and three two one action
yeah let's do one more make the cell it
bounced harder still the bounce Carter
yeah a whole body chase how was that on
your clothes and needs a little extra
flail we're gonna have to modeling it's
three two one action I put 9900 wanted
to clean it off so flora and much more
painful than the fall how do you feel
about taking a bow for the shot any day
fifteen more in me probably have to use
it good and many more over the course of
only got three more bandages so he's
just swinging you're kind of like might
just want to turn and just watch the
soldier go down splat and then kind of
then you start getting from point of how
am I gonna get oh its first up it's over
and then how am I going to get down so
but yeah it's more it's mostly just
about the up at the moment of turning to
see the guy fall good that's funny
cool you need to go again I'm really
looking for a lot of like hitting in the
era you know all right yeah scale of 0
to 10 how exhausting are you uh
exhausted three so happy to be down 11
mmm
oh sweet sweet ground Oh Oh gravity
never leave me again
from day one when we were talking about
doing this project a one-shot in mind
that I really really really wanted to do
and that's when Alex first flips upside
down and she's on the overpass and she's
like standing up and I was like we got
to flip the camera I've got to rotate it
and we got a CR all disoriented and just
be just like accept the fact that we're
just blowing people away with some crazy
CG so yeah I got to do that not of
approval from the camera hey 3 2 1
action
ah great got it yes yeah excellent
they won ton weight me too yeah
incomplete
these ones are so much better than the
metal ones over piety I don't know the
metal ones are pretty legit yeah but
these ones are like super sweet here the
metal ones with the sweetest noise